our friend from sports illustrated
albert breer uh here on the rich history
show sorry albert
i i was late for you here uh but i was
going through
uh the uh the history of marshall
goldberg
uh in my book uh great jews and sports
that i have here
on our set so if you need if you ever
need that for research
uh i've got that for you albert you know
who to reach out to
all right all right well i feel like jay
feedler would be in there all right
like i i don't know if i have all the
names well i could
interestingly enough like uh to just
find uh
marshall goldberg i had to uh sift
through
uh uh hank greenberg obviously very
close and randy grossman
randy grossman the football player was
called rabbi that's the name of his uh
his entry
uh here don't find that in wikipedia but
i had to look him up because i i
actually had no idea who he was
when jj watt uh it was announced was
taking his number thanks to his
thanks to the family's grace good graces
to let him have it i didn't have no idea
yeah yeah i thought that was really cool
too like to me like the effect of that
i'm i mean who cares if the guy's never
tired really you know what i mean like
the effect of that to me was like
that that it really like allowed a lot
of people to kind of educate themselves
a guy who has a really cool story
like so i like i mean they take it out
of circulation
you know if it goes back into
circulation for a couple years so jj can
win it
who can wear it and then you know a
whole bunch of new people who didn't
know
about marshall goldberg now know about
him like that to me is a pretty good
result right well two people who'd left
to mind before i learned who marshall
goldberg was
albert uh in in terms of j.j watts
signing and how it might affect the
immediate um
were were russell wilson and desean
watson
um because if russell's concerned about
his protection
um i would imagine that that sort of
sensibility just got heightened even
more
wouldn't you say yes yeah and i think
like it's it's really interesting to me
like
i think we all kind of you know when a
guy like jj who's you know the tail end
of his career
um you know becomes a free agent we all
just assume the guy's gonna go
like ring chasing right like so it's
like okay like well
you know he's just gonna go you know to
whatever to tampa
to to kansas city like to some place
that's gonna create the easiest path to
a ring
i think sometimes what we discount is
like the personal pride that these guys
have
and you know when you put so much into
your craft maybe wanting to prove
that you you have something left and you
know such a huge part of why jj did this
you know
is that um he's going to a place where
he knows the defensive coordinator vance
joseph was in houston for
his first three years for watts for
three years there
um and the system itself is almost
identical to the wade phillips system
that jj played really well
in those years you know and so the
ability to go there and hit the ground
running play opposite chandler jones
which obviously means
he's probably in its more favorable
match up it gives jj a really good shot
to show he has something left and i i
think with a lot a lot of times when we
look at players and their decisions they
make in
in in spots like this you sort of
discount that sort of thing and i think
it was definitely a fact
well and it's it's i i love the signing
and i again i just love
where he winds up in that in that
division that is so damn
fascinating you know where the fact is
we are barely into march right and free
agency
is the new league gear is about two
weeks away right now
and matthew stafford and jj watt have
already entered this
division that's going to get nick bosa
back from injury and who knows what the
49ers
might do at their quarterback spot but i
just want to linger a little bit on the
russell wilson of it
for a moment with you and and tell me
what what is going on there because if
he is concerned about his protection
if he is if that's the one thing i don't
know how seattle is going to
you know what do they do they make a
free agent signing do they do they
go ahead and draft somebody or do they
just say we're just going to be
who we are and russ is under contract
and that's the end of that or or will
russ
i mean what what happens now do you
think well richie
he had me he had a couple of meetings
after the season um
you know where like he really did
address this stuff and
so you know it was with his own team it
was also a pete carroll
um you know and and really like coming
out of that i know
um that russell sort of felt like there
were three things he wanted to have
accomplished
number one like you know he wanted a
scheme with a new offensive coordinator
that would give him a chance to best
highlight his skills
and that box has already been checked
they brought in shane waldron from the
rams i know he was on board with the
hire
so he liked that that left two more
boxes one was fixing the offensive line
and two was having communication on the
direction of the franchise and what it's
going to look like over the next few
years
and so i think the seahawks were
amenable to that
i think what really pissed the seahawks
off um
you know for lack of a better way of
putting it was sure that he went public
with it and i think part of it for him
was
like i want to create urgency and i want
to put urgency on them
but you have to look at if you're the
seahawks right and you're saying to
yourself okay like
we've already been through so much with
this guy whether it was the friction
with the legion of boom guys or
it was the contract situation that
russell may be wanting a baseball
contract
or if it was the grumbling over those
all those years
with the scheme and with the uh i mean
there was all this stuff
right so you certainly see where the
seahawks are looking at this and saying
to themselves
i mean enough enough like like we need
to fix this and so to me
like you look at all that history right
and the two things that russell has left
on his list
um you know i think those things can be
accomplished but to me like i
i think where the seahawks are on this
is we really need to just kind of put an
end to
to this year-to-year thing where there's
always an issue there's always some
drama
i think what the cs would like is to
find a way
to sit down and meet with him and
try to see if there's a way that where
they can put it to bed where it's not an
issue for the next three or four years
and if they can't put that to bed and
who the hell knows what's going to
happen seven or eight years from now
right like we don't know who's going to
the coach any of that but
at least for the duration of his
contract kind of get to a place where
this isn't a year-to-year
thing where there's always drama and you
know i think that
you know russell going public with a lot
of this stuff is what pushed them to
that point albert breer here on the rich
eisen show i i feel like with the desean
watson
story um or situation however you want
to use it
i feel like i'm watching um you know
like hard cable news
after a major uh piece of news happens
and then i just watch it for 10
12 14 15 straight hours waiting for
the next you know iteration the next
news cycle to actually
affect what i'm talking about or
watching being talked about
non-stop with the story not changing
that's the way i feel
and i feel like at some point i'm going
to be on the phone with somebody like
yourself or another colleague of ours in
the business and something is gonna the
other shoes gonna drop right unless the
texas really feel like the shoes don't
have to drop
what the hell is going on there right
now albert well i have nothing i mean
is the best way to put it i mean i i
think you know unless one until unless
until one of the two sides moves off
their position we sort of are where we
are
and you know i think it's obvious texas
position is we're not moving him
and watson's position is um i don't want
to be here
you know and so like until one of the
sides moves off of that because
off one of those positions then we're
going to be where we're going to be
and um you know i i think one of the
things that puts it in the sort of spot
that you just described
there really is intention right like
there really are there really isn't like
tension on
on the texans to do something right now
um now maybe there will be
like a few weeks down the line but you
know it's it's not like
with you know the eagles and carson
wentz or the the jets and sam darnold
where
you know you got to be worried that like
if you don't move the guy before the
middle of march
seats could start filling up and all of
a sudden now you can't find a suitor and
you can't get value for them desean
watson such a good player
that his value is going to hold so it
doesn't really matter if you trade him
tomorrow
or if you trade him on april 20th and
that's why
to me like this thing is probably going
to be where it is and the texans are
going to probably try to do some more
to fix the relationship before it gets
to the point where he's actually traded
um and and and i i really look at it the
next deadline
to me will be the draft because if you
are going to move to sean watson
i i would think that you would want to
try to get some sort of long-term answer
at the position in return and once you
get past the draft
now you're talking about maybe trading
them for drafting you don't know where
they're going to be
you know obviously in 2022 and you don't
even know
you know what that class is going to
look like there's no trevor lawrence
next year like next year's draft class
looks fairly bereft to quarterback so
like i would say that the draft is
probably the the the time when the
texans might
feel the need to to make a trade or feel
the need to make a decision or feel need
to get some sort of
closure on on the issue um but they
don't have to do it right now and i
think
because nick casario understands he has
such a precious commodity and deshaun
watson a 25 year old top five
quarterback
like it behooves him over the next five
or six weeks
and you know at least until we get
closer to the draft to everything
every single thing he possibly can to
get it done to to get
something to to do something to try and
you know make the situation a little bit
more amenable to whatever deshawn
watson's looking for
but your word choice um is specific for
a reason albert there's a difference
between having to
and should do okay and the the
should do is heads the have to off at
the pass
that if you wait till you have to do it
you don't have nearly as many options
as when you do it when you should do it
and that there is a free agency period
where
a couple of nfc teams where you might be
able to
you might be able to put desean so you
don't see him once every four years
would go uh off the board if they go in
a certain direction or
another team that would be a great spot
for you to land him in
for your own purposes um whether draft
wise or geographically so you don't see
him
once every about once every four years
somebody might fall in love with one of
these aforementioned quarterbacks that
are in this year's draft and just say
you know what as much as we think
desean's great
your price is too damn high and he costs
too damn much
we're just gonna sit back and we love
this kid we're gonna go to work with our
own person
and and the longer you wait by
by ignoring the fact that they have to
is going to come home to roost at some
point
you know that's my issue with this and
that's what i
i keep revisiting literally on a daily
basis
on the show albert yeah i mean i i think
the key is the key
key really is uh to me it's like those
two afc teams right
like so like you look like what the jets
and dolphins have to offer
um you know they both have top three
picks it's perfect
they both have two they both have 23
year old quarterbacks
so yeah i mean you could theoretically i
like with those two teams like say you
like to or you like sam right like
you like if you're the texas you see
erratically could come away with a
quarterback is two years younger than
deshawn and a top three pitch
you know so like to me like those teams
would be the key and how in on they are
and i think both teams are
very very interested would be interested
in desean if he became available
so they're the key to me and then i
think carolina sort of lingering out
there
yes you know i i've been told by several
people that that that uh david tepper
their owner who's still jewish
um you know he's like that he was very
much
like obsessed you know with with getting
the quarterback position right
yeah and would take a very big swing and
would want his football people to take a
very very big swing at deshaun watson so
i mean like as long as those three
situations remain
unresolved as long as those three teams
are there to me like i i think you're
going to be able to get really great
value and even if one drops off the
board like let's say
you know your scenario that joe douglas
and and robert sala
michael floyd they fall in love with
zach wilson right
and we're taking him second overall well
then you still have the dolphins and the
panthers you know so i still think that
you know the presence of those three
teams in the top eight
would at least give you like a really
really good chance to get a great return
for deshawn
and i don't think right now
um that's you know you're going to be in
a situation
six weeks from now where all three of
those options as trade partners would
would dry up albert breer here on the
rich eisen show um
i'll ask you again this could be uh this
could know this this this could be
not age well at all it could be no
longer evergreen five minutes from now
but is drew brees gonna retire i mean
what's going on and what's the saints
quarterback plans
what do you got for me on that i mean i
i
i think he is um you know it was funny
because
and i don't know if you heard this but
this was like a pretty rampant thing
um a very pretty rampant like idea that
i guess is the right way to put it that
i heard
last year that like part of what pushed
drew brees
to come back um you know last year
was that like he knew tom brady had some
interest in new orleans
and so like you know i think like that
there was this idea at least lingering
out there
that drew wasn't going to let tom come
in and win a super bowl with
his team so he was going to come back
and try to do it himself and it was it
was funny
to you know you you heard that it's kind
of like you know one of those things
where
you know i like it you're not talking
about like it's fact but it's just
there were there were bright crumbs
around it and everything else
and somebody pointed out to me over the
weekend do you think it's any
coincidence that drew brees dropped that
video
right after russell wilson put the
saints on his list
no definitely not definitely it's all
related i mean think about that right
isn't that kind of interesting so you're
saying you're saying brees is
comfortable with james following him
but not russell or brady is that is that
the is that what you're kind of picking
up
i look like you know like like i don't
know it might be marking his territory a
little bit there by pushing that leg
get get your trainer out there i'm going
to go push a slide down this street
and show russell whose team it is i
don't know you know i just thought it
was
but somebody brought that up to me so i
thought it was interesting i the one
thing i would say logistically that's
interesting about this
is like wow he's taking a pay cut he
already probably that was
already processed right right right so
on march or on
i think it was would have been february
4th i think it was
um they actually process the pay cut
which was down from about 25 million to
the
to the minimum per player of his age
which is a little over one million so
he took a pay cut of almost 24 million
bucks
already and it's not like he can just
reverse that you know what i mean like
so
like i just i i don't know like
i would breathe come back and play for
the league minimum in 2022
2021 i don't know but to me like that
like into people around the league that
was a pretty clear sign that he's
retiring because the reason you would do
that right um would be to do the team a
favor because that's going to allow them
to carry him on their salary cap
until june 1st at which point they can
cut him and spread the cap
damage out you know and so like there
there is
at least like a tangible piece of
evidence there
that you know brees his plan all along
has been to retire
and for him to unretire at that point
like the saints could actually hold him
to that say okay well if you want to
come back you got to play for the
minimum which is
you know just a crazy idea to think
about but i don't think it'll come to
that my guess is
that we're going to get an announcement
at some point in the near future that
he's retiring and plus you got to be in
shape to do this job in studio because
there's a lot of sitting on your ass
craft services i mean you if you you
need to come in shape
if you're going to start doing studio
stuff because you can get out of shape
pretty much
well maybe you could you have like a do
you have like a training program no i
can call you
guys yes the re1 system i'll send it
down to him
um you know what there's one last
quarterback situation i want to hit you
on before i let you go which is
fascinating to me and
and and uh there's not much talk about
it because we're all focused on that
bright shiny object called lombardi
trophy that
tom brady talked about with james corden
and i'm going to hit that later on in
this show
uh is new england uh you know what what
does
what are they going to do man i mean are
they going to really draft a quarterback
uh first round is it possible jimmy g
could shake loose and there's a reunion
or
alex smith what are their play cam
resigned i mean what do you think
yeah thank you i i think if jimmy g were
to come available they would absolutely
have it
have an interest um you know and i'm
sure you guys have talked about on the
show i just don't think that happens
unless the niners have a clear upgrade
and i'm not saying they're married to
jimmy g but you know
i mean absent like desean maybe they
fall in love with somebody
you know in the draft like i've heard
trey lance from north dakota state
is a is a very would be a very strong
fit for kyle's office so maybe it's
somebody like that
you know trouble it for new england is
can you wait for that
you know what i mean like can you wait
for the night it's like say watson comes
available in april
say you know you say it's one of the
guys in the draft and you know you have
to wait until
after the niners figure out if they're
gonna get their guy or not like
can you afford to to wait that long um
and leave your quarterback situation on
address which is sort
of what put them in the position last
year where they were signing
cam newton on july 1st you know what i
mean like so
i i think that that's the timing part of
this and
this applies to a lot of teams by the
way the timing part of this
um and what they want to do is is
absolutely a factor and so
it wouldn't surprise me if they bring
that cam
on a cheap contract and they have
another veteran there whether it's a
ryan fitzpatrick or a marcus mariota or
whatever
and then they continue evaluating the
quarterbacks in the draft
and again like i think if jimmy were to
come available tomorrow yes absolutely
they would go go and do something like
that but i think the more likely
scenario right now would be maybe to
throw a couple veterans at the position
continue to do your evaluation of all
the guys in the draft
and you know who knows maybe one of them
falls to you and 15 at 15
maybe you see somebody like enough to to
move up
um but i think for right now you know
the pacers are going to be very
aggressive at some other positions
and it wouldn't surprise me if they just
try to give themselves
a couple of veteran options to tread
water with for the time being
albert you're the man thanks for the
call uh look for me next week when i'm
told the the
the cuts are going to be crazy and uh
let's do this on
on the regular if you don't mind
absolutely absolutely thanks richard hey
congratulations on your basketball team
you know i get after you when things are
going bad yes you know jawan's got it
juan's got a pretty good thing going no
i know and you're saying that just
because
my alma mater beat you're the alma mater
uh over the weekend but uh we got we
you know uh the elan i haven't said
dynamite conference the ilana just uh
handed michigan a nice little calling
card yesterday so we'll see how it all
works out
it's crazy man it really i didn't even
see that so i wasn't i would trust me i
wasn't like but
i mean it's like every you you look at
it it's insane it's like every
week it's like you look at the schedule
and there's like a top 10 team on there
for you
for your for your team you know what i
mean thanks for the call albert you're
the man
appreciate it hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here